mais que signifie apprivoiser
qui prince s'assigne
des liens dit le renard
créer des liens oui tu n'es qu'un petit
garçon semblable à cent mille autres au
petit garçon et je suis un renard
semblable à 100000 aux trois renards
mais si tu m'as apprivoise je serais
pour toi unique au monde et tu seras
pour moi unique au monde
mais comment faut-il faire dit le petit
prince
il faut être très patient
tu ta soir après deux mois dans l'herbe
et tu ne diras rien le langage est
source de malentendus dans l'entreprise
le langage est une source de malentendus
je vais vous faire la même réponse
keops avait fait quand on lui a demandé
quelle était la meilleure et la pire des
choses c'est la langue c'est pas de
langage qui est source de malentendus
c'est l'utilisation qu'on peut en faire
alors c'est sûr que si le petit prince
revenait sur terre aujourd'hui
eh bien je lui demanderais de me
dessiner pas une
un mouton dans un bar mais à la pala
j'ai passé ce que c'est qu'un la pala
c'est quelqu'un qui est là mais qui
n'est pas là mais vous en voyez partout
dans l'entreprise déjà acquis vont
parler mais vous écoute pas vous voyez
très bien qu'ils pensent à autre chose
vouliez très bien qu'ils sont en réunion
et qui sont sur leur smartphone alors là
le langage est source de malentendus et
puis je vous parle de l'entreprise mais
c'est vrai chez vous à la maison dans
vos clubs sportifs etc
vous rentrez tiens tu sais j'ai fait ça
aujourd'hui très bien le véritable
langage pour qu'elle ne soit pas source
de malentendu ce que j'ai appris dans la
vie et dans l'entreprise c'est quand on
est présent pour les autres quand on est
dans l'ici et le maintenant
et puis le véritable langage chez celui
qui crée des liens
ici une chose dont je suis certain
maintenant au après toutes mes
expériences celles qui vont pas très
bien réussi et sept corps ici c'est
qu'un facteur commun celle qui réussit
c'est que quand la création de liens est
forte entre les collaborateurs le patron
entre l'entreprise et le client et ce à
tous les niveaux vous crée des liens
forts vous créer de la valeur pour
l'entreprise et je vous donne un exemple
récent que j'aime beaucoup ça se passe
aux etats-unis dans une maison de
retraite cette maison de retraite a
décidé pour créer des liens de créer une
règle toute bête qui s'appelle la règle
des 10 5
je suis à dix mètres d'un résident de la
maison de retraite
eh bien je lui fais un signe je
communique
je suis à moins de 5 mètres je vais lui
dire quelque chose je vais porter une
parole
au bout d'un an de test on compare cette
maison de retraite aux autres maisons de
retraite du même groupe qui ne
pratiquent pas la règle 10 5
résultat des courses 15 % de
productivité en plus quel est le
dirigeant d'entreprise qui ferait pas
n'importe quoi pour obtenir 10% 15% de
productivité en plus mais au-delà de ces
15 % de productivité en plus qui sont
très vertueux parce que l'entreprise est
là pour performer
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
commence à mesurer la longévité des
patients dans cette maison de retraite
et on s'aperçoit déjà aujourd'hui on n'a
pas tous les résultats parce qu'il faut
attendre que les gens vivent plus
longtemps que dans d'autres maisons du
même groupe pour lequel il n'y a pas la
règle des 10 5
croyez moi la communication écrit et la
communication qui crée des liens permet
de créer de la valeur par rapport à ça
je peux que vous conseiller de suivre
des cours de communication pour vous en
tant que collaborateurs d'entreprise en
tant que dirigeant mais pour votre vie
aussi alors là dessus il ya plein de
très bons tedx il ya plein de très bons
ouvrages
mais ce qu'on va vous apprendre ce qui
est très important et qui est d'ailleurs
un peu fou parce que c'est une étude qui
le dit quelle est la part de la
communication à travers les bons à
travers
le langage expression orale et puis à
travers le visuel c'est la règle des 3 v
le verbe le mot ce que véhicule le mot
cette étude 17% alors ils sont pas tout
à fait exact il ya des billets dans
cette étude
mais ce qui compte c'est la dérive et
c'est l'attention 7%
quand vous parlez du vocal la façon dont
je m'exprime montons des intonations ses
37 % de ce qui va passer et tout le
reste c'est le visuel c'est le langage
du corps
et ce sont les différentes diapositives
powerpoint
tout ce que vous voulez que vous avez
passé pour effet essayé de communiquer
quelque chose et essayer de communiquer
quelque chose est de mettre en motion de
mettre en mouvement
l'émotion c'est de mettre les gens en
mouvement et si dans l'entreprise vous
voulez mettre vos équipes en mouvement
ce que tout dirigeant souhaite
eh bien il faut faire aussi appel à
l'émotion d'où le fait que les visuels
apporte souvent un langage émotionnel
qu'on voit beaucoup moins dans la force
des mots ce que j'ai appris c'est qu'au
delà de tous ces cours que vous pourrez
avoir et de ses conseils qu'ils sont
beaux et qui sont importants pour vous
dans votre vie professionnelle dans
votre vie personnelle
ce que j'ai appris c'est qu'un langage
qui porte un langage qui n'est pas
source de malentendus c'est quand il est
habité par une intention positive quand
on s'est posé une intention à ce qu'on
va communiquer aux autres et là dessus
c'est aussi une une belle expérience qui
a été fait avec des élèves
on a pris un groupe d'élèves et on les a
séparés en deux ans tirant au sort
à partir de là on a dit aux mêmes
professeurs qui allait avoir ses deux
groupes des lèvres voyez si ce groupe là
ce sont les cadors c'est des fusées
c'est vraiment les meilleurs vous savez
sacrément la chance
et puis on a dit là c'est ce que disait
de moi d'une bande de copains quand
j'étais à l'école
la bande des nullards du du fond de la
classe là c'est les cancres et on a
passé un trimestre et dieu soit loué on
va passer qu'un seul trimestre et au
bout du trimestre je vous vois imaginez
déjà les résultats qui peuvent sortir
d'une telle détermination une telle
intention ce qui devait arriver est
arrivé
ce qu'était présupposés intelligents ont
eu de très bons résultats et ceux qui
étaient prêts supposer qu'en crawl de
mauvais résultats mais pourquoi on est
toujours dans l'intention
je voudrais juste un exemple l'exemple
c'est le professeur qui pose à un élève
intelligent dans le groupe des supposés
intelligent une question compliquée une
question un peu bizarre qu'on ne
comprend pas auxerre se dit oulala
l'élève il est intelligent
donc je vais reformuler ma question je
vais lui demander un feedback qu'est ce
que tu veux dire par là et c'est
l'intention de s'intéresser à l'autre
d'avoir un vrai langage entre nous soit
dit le feedback et la reformulation
c'est fondamental dans la vie et dans
l'entreprise pour être sûr de bien se
comprendre de manière à part être source
de malentendus vous êtes dans le groupe
des cancres qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors là c'est très simple écoute si
c'est pour me poser une question comme
ça tu ferais mieux de pas la poser c'est
la vérité c'est comme ça que ça se passe
donc à partir de cette expérience si
vous voulez ça n'a fait que me confirmer
ce que je peux vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est que si on a une intention positif
par rapport à nos collaborateurs et une
intention dans l'alignement
c'est à dire que si vous pensez quelque
chose mais que au niveau du coeur etc au
niveau des tripes et qui a pas cet
alignement que trip vraiment vous
ressentez ça passera
pas et surtout quand vous avez des
choses difficiles annoncer l'alignement
il est fondamental et là c'est aussi
l'exemplarité du management
j'ai un exemple qui qui m'inspiraient
pendant une grande partie de ma vie et
de ma carrière c'est l'exemple de gandhi
un jour une femme bien avec son fils qui
est diabétique voir gandhi et elle lui
dit écoutez m pourriez-vous dire à mon
fils d'arrêter de manger du sucre parce
que c'est très mauvais pour lui il veut
mettre la regarde et lui dit s'il vous
plaît revenez dans quinze jours ils
reviennent un jour après le mahatma voit
l'enfant et lui parle lui explique en
quoi c'est pas bon pour lui c'est pas
bon pour les gens qui sont autour de lui
et le convainc arrêter de manger du
sucre et la maman le regarde et qui met
m pourquoi vous lui ai pas dit ça il ya
quinze jours il ya quinze jours je
mangeais du sucre
donc c'est pas compliqué d'être un
manager aligner un manager qui crée des
liens
il suffit vraiment d'être dans une
intention positive au niveau de votre
alignement de ressentir ce que vous
pensez de dire ce que vous faites de
faire ce que vous dites
les américains disent oh god toc et
c'est fondamental si vous voulez que ça
marche
je vais vous donner un autre exemple de
notre expérience qui est prouvée sur ce
sujet vous connaissez tous l'effet
placebo l'effet placebo on vous dit
écoute et voilà vous allez prendre ce
médicament c'est très bien ça vous
soigner sauf que c'est du sucre n'est
pas dicaments résultat de l'effet
placebo classique 10% des personnes sont
soignées
c'est quand même déjà super bien vous
faites
l'effet placebo au deuxième niveau
je m'explique le médecin qui va
prescrire qui va recommander le
soi-disant médicaments ne sait pas lui
même que c'est du sucre
il est convaincu que c'est un bon
médicament
l'effet placebo va avoir l'effet va être
multiplié par 3 30 % de personnes seront
guéris pourquoi parce que le médecin au
fond de lui même dans son alignement le
plus total or à véhiculer le message que
effectivement ça soigne puisqu'il le
crois profondément
10 30 % la force de l'intention comment
on habite ses pensées en étant aligné et
en ayant un langage qui ne soit pas
source de malentendus on le sait
également j'ai eu la chance de manager
des grands centres d'appels dans les
centres d'appels des premières choses
qu'on apprend et j'étais très surpris au
début vous savez le le sourire s'entend
au téléphone donc souriez au téléphone
c'est contre intuitif parce qu'on dit au
téléphone je peux faire monter en même
temps le
le client le etc il ne verra pas bien
sûr que si parce que ce que vous allez
ressentir le sourire va avoir un effet
sur vous même déjà positif et ça des
neurosciences le prouve vous seriez vous
modifiez les parties de votre cerveau
qui va avoir un effet directement sur
votre être et sur votre langage et sur
votre intonation et ça passera au
téléphone donc encore une fois la force
de l'alignement éprouvée par ce type
d'étude et ce type de résultat voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire aujourd'hui sur
sur le langage
je vais vous citer quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup qui s'appelle françois chang
qui est un académicien française vous
devez bien connaître aussi il dit que
les esprits résonne au sens de la raison
sens de descartes et dans l'entreprise
on est là pour raisonner on est là pour
mettre du cartésianisme les esprits
résonnent les âmes résonne au sens de
résonance et effectivement si vous
voulez entrer en communication et que
cette communication ne soit pas source
de malentendus il faut arriver à rentrer
dans cette résonance sincère et
authentique et à ce moment là je peux
vous assurez vous allez créer des liens
qui sont juste extraordinaire il vous
risquez d'avoir des résultats juste
extraordinaire
quel que soit le groupe que vous dirigez
que ce soit dans l'entreprise dans le
sport dans l'associatif la force des
liens est très importante
et enfin comme on a commencé avec
saint-exupéry je vais finir sur lui
j'aime beaucoup cette phrase qui dit
qu'on ne voit bien qu'avec le coeur mais
que l'essentiel est invisible pour les
yeux
comme on est ce soir sur le langage je
vais vous dire que on entend bien
qu'avec le coeur
l'essentiel est inaudible pour les
oreilles merci beaucoup de m'avoir
écouté
[Applaudissements]